[Music]
we know that probability is a measure of
uncertainty of events in a random
experiment
also we have established the equivalence
between the axiomatic theory and the
classical theory of probability in case
of equally likely outcomes
now we will be talking about an
important concept of probability called
the conditional probability
so what is conditional probability
you would have seen a notation like this
p of a vertical bar b
we pronounce this as the conditional
probability of a given b
this vertical line means given
now what does this probability mean
it means given that the outcome of a
random experiment satisfies b
how likely it is that it will also
satisfy a
in other words
what are the chances of the occurrence
of the event a
when given that the event b has already
occurred
if a and b are dependent events
the knowledge of the occurrence of event
b is going to impact the chances of
occurrence of event a
let's understand this using an
interesting example
we have cheteshwar pujara batting in the
first innings of an international test
match
how likely is it that he will score a
hundred given that he's already scored a
half century
now here we have to find the probability
that chateshwar pujara will score a 100
in the first innings given that he's
already scored 50 runs
to find this probability we need some
information about his past performances
like how many times has he converted a
50 into 100 while batting in the first
innings
this data is easily available on the
internet
based on our research it turns out that
out of 76 first innings in which he is
battered
31 times he scored half centuries
and 16 out of the 31 times he's gone on
to score 100 runs or more now what can
we do with this data
this data can help us to predict the
likelihood of whether he will score a
century in the ongoing first innings of
a test match after scoring 50
runs the probability that he will score
100 or more runs given that he scored
half a century will be simply given by
16 by 31
where 31 is the total number of times
that he'd scored a 50 in the first
innings
and 16 is the number of times he's
converted those 50s into hundreds
the probability is approximately equal
to 52
now the probability of pujara scoring a
hundred given that he scored 50 in the
first innings is not equal to the
probability of pujara scoring a hundred
in the first innings
the probability of pujara scoring 100 in
the first innings is given by 16 by 76
which is 21
thus we can see that both these
probabilities are different
now let's see if we can represent this
mathematically
if we consider a to be the event that
pujara scores 50 runs
and b be the event that pujara scores
100 runs
observe that 16 here is the number of
times pujara scored 150 runs
hence 16 here is nothing but n of b
intersection a
and 31 is simply the number of times he
scores a 50.
hence it is n of a
now we can adjust n of s in the
numerator and the denominator as shown
hence we get p of b intersection a upon
p of a
so the probability of b given a is given
by this formula
here the numerator p of b intersection a
is the probability that pujara scores
150 runs
that is both the events happening
and the denominator p of a is the
probability that pujara scores 50 runs
hence with that we've seen a practical
example of conditional probability
we hope that you've enjoyed this video
now next we will learn the standard
approach for finding the conditional
probability in simple
examples so see you in the next video
[Music]